Nigeria's recent presidential election
has shaken up its governing party
although it won the vote it has also
lost a lot of ground to the opposition
in Battleground States like Kano
analysts say the losses could spread to
the next round of election for some
State Governors these Governors do form
because they do not even know the need
of the people all there after is power
power I want to acquire it they are
confused
Nigeria's governing party is in charge
in the northern state of Gumby the
governor acknowledges the setbacks of
the presidential election but says his
party is unfazed by a stubborn
opposition
we are very comfortable and let's see
what comes out of the governorship
that's coming up I believe the apc2 will
still win more States and at least
maintain whatever we have before
or state Governors and legislators
closer to voters in the presidency and
the Parliament
these elections are expected to draw
more voters
Rising balance poverty and economic
decline have brought hardship to many
Nigerians this has generated anger and
body apathy in the February 25
presidential election now as they go to
the polls again some voters say they
want to punish their representatives for
their dismal performance in office
in Nigeria the office of Governor
carries a lot of responsibilities but
also wields a lot of power including
helping to decide who becomes president
s that political parties here
desperately want to keep the states they
hold
and win more
Ahmed Idris al-jazeera gwambe Nigeria